Guten Morgen Tim ja selbstverständlich ja habe ich auch nicht live gestreamt.
Logbuch Netzpolitik Nummer 290 vom 7 März 2019 direkt live aus der Metaebene mit mir dem Tim dem Dinos und wir haben auch
einen Gast dabei heute.
Hallo Markus Markus Reuter von netzpolitik.org wo du fleißig schreibst und dir die Themen die ausgeben.
Ja ist der Technik sogar so gerade ist uploadfilter dass mich das große Ding aber auch sonst gibt's ja immer was zu berichten.
Immer.
So ist es.
Dann haben wir ja in der letzten Sendung vorgestellt 22019 die,
vorletzte Mann geht das diskutiert Schlag auf Schlag die Aktion.
Industrielles das hier ge.
Industrie der DDR der demokratisch legitimierte Komplex hat hier oder der Demokratie industrielle komplex hat ja hier bot Anrufe freigeschaltet
und Neider dieser Bots hat mir dann eine automatisierte E-Mail geschrieben,
und es hat sich ein interessanter Austausch ergeben zwischen
Martin und Thomas und mir und wir fanden das ganz interessante deswegen den Martin jetzt auch hier live life on the internet bei uns in der Sendung hallo Martin.
Ja hallo Linus.
Du hast bei clash 20910 mitgemacht und du hast ein bisschen geschrieben dass das jetzt irgendwie das erste Mal ist dass du dich an so etwas beteiligst erzähl doch mal so ein bisschen wie das wieso deine Erfahrungen da waren.
Also zuerst möchte ich mal erwähnen dass ich mich als mir
ganz normalen durchschnittlichen höherer von von logbuch-netzpolitik sehe ich bin politisch sehr interessiert mit
technische background ohne aber fünf Charakter her würde ich sagen er tendenziell eher so ein bisschen introvertiert,
und mein bisherigen Beiträge soll immer zu timokratie wo wählen gehen und ja hin und wieder vielleicht meine Petition unterschreiben,
was ich auch bei change.org ist die aktuelle Petition also früh gemacht habe,
aber das war's eigentlich mit meiner direkten Beteiligung bis dahin.
Und du hast jetzt gesagt ich habe mich über Pletsch ja beteiligt,
das ist nicht ganz richtig bei mir war es aber hat es angefangen am am 13. Februar eigentlich als Julia redet dann den endgültigen text,
da veröffentlicht hat.
Noch viel früher also.
Ja ja genau und,
da habe ich dann gedacht okay jetzt jetzt ist es genug dann habe ich mir erstmal überlegt er soll ich die E-Mails schreiben aber ich habe mein Auge,
ja ist mir schnell bewusst geworden ich habe sehr viel versäumt dadurch dass ich mich bisher nicht beteiligt habe und ich habe gedacht okay jetzt jetzt rufst du einfach mal an,
und was ich dann gemacht habe ist ich habe bei der Partei die ich jetzt am ehesten wählen würde habe ich mal geschaut wie haben die Abgeordneten abgestimmt habe gesehen und paar haben im September dafür gestimmt,
dann habe ich gedacht du da muss ich mal nachhaken habe dann auch noch geschaut das oder wer von den dann wieder gewählt werden möchte,
das ist übrigens auch was was auf den Webseiten vielleicht noch irgendwie fehlt also auf,
vielleicht auch verletzt oder auch auf safe save your internet welche von denen möchte eigentlich wieder gewählt werden weil ich habe gesehen da stehen auch nicht alle zur Wiederwahl.
Du meinst einige sitzen dann sagen, ich zitiere noch mal die Scheiße an nach mir die Sintflut ist mir doch egal ja ok Arbeit ich verstehe die natürlich wenn man wenn man sie bei dem wenn man sie da greifen möchte.
Das macht ja auch durchaus Leute geben die im Wesentlichen nach ihrer Parlament Zeit nur noch eine Beschäftigung in der Wirtschaft suchen und da ist dann Hopfen und Malz verloren und.
Oh ja das ist richtig die haben vielleicht schon längst ein Vertrag ne okay also wer wiedergewählt werden möchte darauf sollten wir achten.
Genau da war mein mein Fokus und dann habe ich mir und ich denke das ist es sehr entscheidend ich habe jetzt mich nicht so an denen,
verbreiteten Meinung entlang gehangelt die so überall,
zu finden sind so an ich habe mir tatsächlich meine eigene Meinung gebildet und meine eigenen also ich sage mal die Stellen die mich am meisten beschäftigen
mit Artikel 11 und 13 habe ich muss aufgeschrieben und hab dann gedacht,
okay jetzt sitzt jetzt rufst du einfach mal an und mein erster Kontakt der war wirklich wirklich hervorragend ich habe,
sehr nervös muss ich sagen habe ich dort angerufen weil man weiß ja nie wen wen hat man denn da dran,
er hatte dann aber ein sehr sehr freundlichen Kontakt und,
ja ich habe mich auch erstmal gesagt ja ok hier ich bin der und der und deutscher Staatsbürger,
bin besorgt mit bezüglich Artikel 11 und 13 und ja ich würde gerne,
mal hören warum denn Herr soundso im September dagegen gestimmt hat dafür gestimmt hat sorry und ja das wird dann auch gern so wird auch in meine Wahlentscheidung mit einfließen.
Und da muss ich sagen da war dann auch das Eis gebrochen ist eine sehr sehr nette Assistentin.
Die mir auch zu verstehen gegeben hat dass der Abgeordnete um den sich der gehandelt hat,
aus dem Grund dagegen gestimmt hat im September weil dort noch keine uploadfilter drin waren jetzt sind nach seiner Auffassung uploadfilter in dem Text drin,
und jetzt hat er sich als mittlerweile hatte sich auch auf Pletsch 20910 dafür ausgesprochen dass er dagegen stimmen wird,
unam ja dass das war das war schon mal sehr interessant,
das hat mir dann auch sehr viel Motivation gegeben dann mal meine Liste weiter abzuarbeiten und ich muss sagen die Erfahrung war wirklich durchweg positiv,
hat sich meine Argumente angehört,
ich habe auch die Meinung also der einzelnen Politiker mitbekommen das halt vorgetragen von den Assistenten.
Und dass dass das hat mir wirklich! Viel Motivation gegeben zu dem Zeitpunkt muss ich aber sagen habe ich,
noch keinen CDU la angerufen gehabt.
Russisches verkohlt.
Ja und dann dann kam dann kam der Moment wo ich gesagt ob du jetzt das war nicht alles so positiv jetzt jetzt ruf mal einen von der dunklen Seite an und hörst einfach mal an,
was was die sind zu sagen haben also nimm mich jetzt wirklich interessiert was ist denn so die offizielle Stellungnahme von denen Vivi wir stehen wieder im demgegenüber.
Und auch hier muss ich sagen also eben das war das war alles am 14. Februar aber da war wirklich,
die ganze Kontakt war durchweg freundlich und positiv er natürlich hat man häufig auch die Standard Life davon gehört zu erheben,
Rechte der da oder besser Rechte der für die Copyright Inhaber und und so weiter und und gegen diese großen Plattform und also die ganz normale Leier sage ich mal,
und auch wenn wo ich dann meine,
Bedenken vorgetragen habe hier ist das wissen sie dass das ist ja im im Text steht das ja steht das ja drinnen ist das abgedeckt was ich dann aber auch gemacht habe ist ich habe da eingehakt und ich habe gesagt ja okay also.
Das ist also ab,
ja wie stellen sich das denn vor wie das z.b. abläuft mit denen Dezenz Vereinbarungen mit den Rechteinhaber ne dass ich habe da ein bisschen so auf auf die Themen ein,
hey bin ich eingegangen hab da noch mal nachgehakt da wird dann auch auf die nationale Gesetzgebung verwiesen und ja eben da muss man dann gucken wie die Rechtsprechung dann mache ausfällt und so weiter und dann ich gesagt ja okay aber,
an dem Punkt ist es zu spät dann ist das Kind schon Brunnen gefallen.
Und was ich auch noch gesagt habe ist eben ja gut also ich vertraue ihnen einfach mal wenn das in die Hose geht weiß ich ja wo ich mich dann wieder melden kann.
Das ist das war eigentlich soweit meine Erfahrungen mit den CDU Land jetzt möchte ich noch auf eine ganz spezielle Erfahrung eingehen und zwar.
Mit einem Abgeordneten da habe ich einen sehr guten Kontakt gehabt und ihm bis dato habe ich keine E-Mail geschrieben gehabt und die Abgeordneten sind aber schon in der E-Mail-Flut untergegangen,
und der Assistent hat dann wirklich meine Argumente von der wirklich so spannend,
dass er mich er hat mich gebeten ihm eine E-Mail zu schreiben,
und die zu und die zusammen unten also die die Argumente zusammenzufassen weil tatsächlich er die weitergeben möchte damit sein Abgeordneten diese Argumente vielleicht auch in den,
Aktions internen Diskurs einbringen kann.
Heute mal kurz einhaken was was sind denn mwl ohne jetzt vielleicht alles aufzuschneiden aber welche Argumente waren in dass die den jetzt neu oder besonders überzeugend rüber kam
das welche die die die du dir jetzt so selber erdacht hast oder im Wesentlichen auch nur das was unserer Meinung nach eigentlich um gängige Raum rum.
Ja also ich habe mich ein bisschen auf die technische Schiene sag ich mal soll ich mal eingeschossen also ich habe auch ein bisschen background in.
Ich nenne statistisches lernen ich ich möchte nicht diese Passwörter benutzen.
Sehr gut.
Und habe dann auch seitlich mal gezielt drauf drauf hingewiesen.
Die Algorithmen einfach nicht funktionieren das man technisch auch noch nicht soweit ist,
ich habe Beispiele gebracht ich war gerade aktuell in im Januar war ich z.b. auf einer Konferenz in Lausanne woselbst einer von Google also ein Forscher von Google vorgetragen hat das.
Heute Probleme mit ihren Algorithmen mit ihren neuronalen Netzen und dass das denke ich war so,
Punkt wo du gesagt haben aha okay also da sitzt jemand der sich da auch technischer mit ausgehen,
und das deshalb sage ich mal so ein bisschen bei mir jetzt die Tür geöffnet aber ich denke jeder sollte mit seinen eigenen Argumenten kommen mit seinen größten Bedenken und unten darauf dann dann reingehen.
Und dann ja also im im weiteren Verlauf war das dann so dass ich gedacht habe ok ich konzentriere mich jetzt speziell auf diesen einen Abgeordneten.
Weil ich auch gar nicht die Zeit habe und da sage ich mal noch bei noch mehr Leuten bisschen ein bisschen Druck zu machen.
Finde ich reicht ja auch ne.
Ja ja also das hat aber es hat es hat auch wirklich absolut Früchte getragen dass ich habe da mehrmals angerufen und ich habe eine E-Mail Kontakt mit dem wie man mit dem gleichen Assistentin.
Und das ging jetzt eigentlich so also immer wenn wenn es eine neue aktuelle Entwicklung gab habe ich ja noch mal angerufen ob gemeint ja wie steht Herr soundso denn dazu.
Und das ist jetzt soweit dass ich im Angebot bekommen habe tatsächlich dass der Abgeordnete persönlich mit mir sprechen möchte,
ich habe jetzt genau vor der Sendung auch noch mal mit dem Assistenten telefoniert,
das wird wahrscheinlich nächste Woche stattfinden das Gespräch genauer Termin muss noch gefunden werden,
sehr wahrscheinlich sehr wahrscheinlich per Telefon ich habe auch angeboten also ich komme auch gerne mal in Straßburg vorbei und zeig euch auch noch mal ein bisschen die Probleme auf das wird leider,
zeitlich vermutlich nicht hinhauen aber eben dieses dieses Gespräch das wird mir zugesagt und da da hoffe ich darauf dass es auch stattfindet.
Und ja das ist das ist eigentlich meine Erfahrung die ich da gemacht.
Und ich möchte jetzt auch noch mal kurz gerne ein bisschen an Aufruf starten was was die Leute in aktuell machen sollten denn,
brauchte mehr.
Kurze Nachfrage noch habe ich jetzt was überhört aber du hast jetzt noch nicht gesagt wer mit wem du da in direkter Verbindung bist so.
Ja
Über einen deutschen Abgeordneten.
Es handelt sich um einen deutschen CDU-Abgeordneten der denke ich auch ein bisschen Gewicht in der Fraktion hat ich möchte jetzt noch seinen Namen noch nicht.
Okay ich dachte ich hätte.
Einfach einfach weil ich ich möchte ich möchte nicht dass er noch mal vielleicht einen Rückzieher macht unter Umständen man weiß ja nie.
Nee alles gut na dann mach mal dein auf.
Ja also was ich was ich eben geben eben sagen kann also jeder der hier zuhört und noch nicht irgendwie angerufen hat oder eine E-Mail geschrieben hat Leute macht das.
Jedoch muss ich sagen E-Mails,
sind aktuell sag ich mal ein Problem also ich weiß von nicht nur von dem einen Abgeordneter nicht von allen die ich,
den ich gesprochen habe die meisten E-Mails und das ist Grundsicherung Problem sind wirklich,
seras lastik und und dass das tut einfach der ganzen Diskussion nicht gut und die werden auch direkt gelöscht,
auch E-Mails mit dem mit dem Standardtext den es auf selfie Internet,
zu finden gibt es so viele kopieren den einfach eins zu eins ohne irgendwelche Personalisierung der wird auch direkt gelöscht ist es die Aussage und,
das auch ein Grund warum mich der Assistent gebeten hat überhaupt die E-Mail an ihn zu schreiben und zwar,
leider Gottes ist wirklich anscheinend so dass ich einer der wenigen bin die ihr Anliegen friedlich,
und und sag nicht vortragen und.
Bomben auf Argumente kommen mit über die man wirklich diskutieren kann,
unter ich denke ich denke das ist aktuell wirklich das Wichtigste also Standard E-Mail,
dass das wird nicht helfen ich habe auch die Deebot Diskussion einmal geführt und gemeint ja,
wie kann wie kann die könnt ihr davon ausgehen dass es alle Spots sind dann hieß es ja das ist immer der gleiche Text der der keiner von sonst wem geschickt werden.
Ja okay lass dich jetzt einfach mal unkommentiert interessant war aber auch die Aussage
na wenn das Briefe gewesen sind also früher hat man Briefe geschrieben und da ist ja eigentlich ganz klar dass da auch ein Mensch dahinter steckt er sich da Mühe gemacht hat,
und deswegen muss ich jetzt sagen,
wenn ihr nicht also idealerweise ruft angeht auf pledge 20.19 und und und nutzt das Angebot und ruft euren Abgeordneten an,
am wenn nicht dann würde ich sagen die wollen Briefe die sollen Brief über.
Gibt's jetzt auch ein Angebot oder dieses bot Brief EU.
Ganz genau,
ganz ganz genau ist ist eine ist eine super Sache da kann man seinen Abgeordneten auswählen die man schreiben möchte es gibt dort auch einen vorgefertigten Text den man aber dann noch ändern kann
diese Fassung kann man runterladen ausdrucken,
signieren ich denke das ist auch sehr wichtig also das ist n entweder generell handgeschrieben ist oder zumindest signierte so wirklich zeigt er das da steckt kein ja keine Automatisierung dahinter.
Man kann das vielleicht auch bei Amazon Mechanical Turk noch mal von jemanden mit Hand abschreiben.
Holen wir uns mal 100 in Meran.
Keine Bots das sind Inder.
Ja ganz ganz genau aber eben ich denke jetzt jetzt ist es eigentlich an der Zeit wirklich idealerweise die die Büros mit E-Mails zu fluten ich meinen.
Getriebemeister.
Ja sorry ganz genau mit Briefen mit Briefen
einfach ich denke dass dass das zeigt den da auch mal die Tragweite also ich sag nur wenn wenn die jetzt da ein paar 1000 E-Mails in im im Postfach haben,
ja die sind mit ein paar Klicks gelöscht dass dass das nie ich denke sie müssen jetzt mal ein Gefühl dafür bekommen wie viel Menschen wirklich dahinter stehen.
Also ich habe einen ich habe das die Telefonanrufe angeht
Jan bisschen Einblick in die statistischen Zahlen die da so aufschlagen das dürfte jetzt noch nicht ganz besonders schlimm sein Arbeit aber da kommen natürlich relativ viele,
dadada klingelt schon denke ich mal bei allen Abgeordneten das Telefon da bekomme ich aber auch von anderen Hörerinnen und Hörern
durchaus auch das Feedback dass sie sagen naja die also E-Mails sind auf jeden Fall irgendwie nerven da und Verdächtiger aber auch in den,
Telefonen sagt sie rufen Sie bitte nicht noch mal an,
ja dass dass das stört uns hier finde ich natürlich dann auch so ein bisschen schwierig ich habe das ja
also dafür sind die halt da um da dran zu gehen jetzt ist natürlich die Frage wie viele Leute rufen da auch wirklich in Ruhe vorbereitet an und tragen da eine differenzierte Erwägung vor,
das ist leider immer eine Minderheit ne egal was du machst das Leute sich wirklich detailliert dann noch mal damit auseinandersetzen und da bin ich bin ich auch so vom Gefühl her.
Zwiegespalten weil einerseits ist das ja einfach gut wenn wir Leute sagen hier ich muss das jetzt auch nicht zum hundertsten Mal vortragen im EU-Parlament wird das Ganze hält seit
weiß nicht anderthalb Jahren debattiert da werde ich jetzt vielleicht nichts Neues mehr beitragen können also sage ich einfach nur huhrensohn aber
trotzdem wie die Leute weiter bringen wenn man wenn der wirklich halt auch getan vor allem dieser,
Autokauf von wie die Menschen wieder anrufen die haben sich auch damit auseinandergesetzt.
Sie meint es ernst die meint es ernst im Sorgen das muss doch den persönliches wichtig und natürlich freundlich das zu sagen aber dann.
Absolut.
Ich bin hier der Bürgerinnen und Bürger der,
Rechte Sorge um Demokratie und Meinungsfreiheit und sonders kann man ja und dann eben diese technischen Argumente für dich habe ich auch gut was das Ganze ein bisschen runter.
Dass das fällt hinten runter und der merkt ja wirklich auch die die absurdesten.
Argumentation wo es wirklich inzwischen schwer wird den den überhaupt noch zu begegnen wenn man gar nicht weiß wo man anfangen sollen also wenn du irgendwie künstliche Intelligenz Park dein Auto rückwärts an weg.
Können wir uns bitte kurz also das ist Algorithmus das war das Passwort vom letzten Jahr so ihr kommt doch mal wenigstens auf die aktuellen Bass oder so ne das ist sicherlich sehr sehr schön wenn da,
mit Kompetenz und Sachverstand begegnet wird.
Hast du sonst noch einen letzten oder vorletzten Briefe schreiben eigene Argumente darlegen völlig egal wie quasi der Hauptsache sind wirklich selber formulierte,
was was hättest du noch.
Also,
generell im mach das für mich war es eine ganz tolle Erfahrung muss ich wirklich sagen es hat mich auch wirklich sehr motiviert da weiterzumachen also es hat so ein bisschen hat sich so angefühlt wie ja ok.
Letztes Mal die Segel und betritt jetzt mal unbekannte Gewässer,
ich muss sagen ja da kam dann recht schnell eben ein Windstoß hat mich zweimal von der Küste der der Komfortzone weggetragen also die ist die ist schon lange am Horizont verschwunden aber,
es ist ein tolles Gefühl und was ich jetzt auch gemacht habe.
Gerade heute bestärkt auch durch seine vorgegangen Gespräche mit mit dir Linus und auch mit thomas,
habe ich mich jetzt dazu entschlossen eine Website zu also ein Blog zu machen und zwar.
I am citizen. EU der ist jetzt noch nicht live ich hoffe wenn das ausgestrahlt wird wird der live sein da möchte ich meine,
meine persönlichen Erfahrungen auch noch mal ausführlich darstellen,
und auf info.at beim citizen. EU biete ich auch jedem anderen Hörer an,
schick mir doch eure eure Erlebnisse also das was ich erlebt habe als durchweg positiv ich habe aber auch schon ebenso wie du vorhin auch erwähnt hast Linus da gibt's auch teilweise negative,
Momente schick mir doch eure Erfahrungen,
und ich werde versuchen Dir auch noch dort hochzuladen die Idee ist wirklich Leute zu motivieren,
aktiv zu werden dann wenn die Leute sehen habe okay der hat das gemacht er hat das gemacht im alle positive Erfahrung gemacht ja komme ich ich mache das auch und mein Mann mein Wunsch wäre das auch noch weiter.
In der Zukunft noch weiter durchzuziehen,
weil es endet ja nicht mit jetzt der Abstimmung über die Copyright directive egal wie die aussieht ist es wird immer noch andere Themen geben und ich denke dass das ganz ist ja wichtig und mir liegt es sehr am Herzen.
Zumal Du ja dann einmal aufgebauten Kontakt pflegen kann ne.
Das hoffe ich ja sofern er.
Persönlich ferngesteuerter ferngesteuerte CDU-Politiker.
Also ich habe jetzt da jetzt deine Webseite ja noch nicht komplett online ist
kann mir das gut vorstellen dass du mit deiner ruhigen Art auch einfach mal konkrete Hinweise auf so die eigentliche Dialogführung die da vorteilhaft ist gehen
wird auch selber coil Service machen das alle erstmal die irgendwo anrufen wollen bei dir auflaufen und wird durch deine Clearingstelle durchkommt der wird dann hoch,
so CDU-Politiker Hand gelassen hast können schon mal helfen nee ich meine mal ehrlich und viele fragen sich ja immer,
was kann ich eigentlich dazu beitragen ich bin ja nur kompetent in was auch immer für ein Feld ne aber wenn man jemand ist der irgendwie im Callcenter arbeitet wenn man jemand ist der weiße der einfach so Gespräche mit Menschen auch täglich führt oder überhaupt,
aus anderen Gründen Psychologiestudium was auch immer einfach so den Umgang mit Menschen irgendwie innerhalb oder einfach was ich als Kind schon immer die Knie geschliffen hat so dass man schon hilfreich sein weil manchmal ist es einfach nur
die Art und Weise wie man vorgeht und gar nicht so sehr der große Köcher der Argumente des der hilft immer Sorgen aber wir wissen wer,
Spaß haben will muss freundlich sein und das geht natürlich auch im politischen Bereich.
Ganz genau ganz genau und wenn jemand höher wenn jemand Fragen hat vielleicht auch doch noch einen kleinen Schubs braucht er kann kann sich gerne auch bei mir melden ich.
Super erstmal vielen vielen Dank für dein Engagement in dem Bereich und dass du das auch hier geteilt hast und ich wünsche dir viele weitere positive Erfahrung und viel Erfolg.
Mal gucken wie es ausgeht.
Nicht dass es am Ende eine eine bittere Enttäuschung wird für dich necans glaube ich jetzt auch gar nicht mehr werden oder.
Nee also und und wenn sage ich mal dass das Risiko dass das ist es mir jetzt wert wenn ich mich jetzt hier auch vor allen hören und umhören zum zum Affen macht es das nehme ich einfach mal einkaufen und ich schaue einfach mal wohin die Reise.
Da gehe ich nicht voraus dass du dich damit ihr zum Affen gemacht hast leuchtendes Beispiel.
Nee überhaupt nicht also ich meine muss ja nur jeder einen Abgeordneten umdrehen dann geht's.
Einfach ganz einfach nicht das Problem.
Jetzt zur Abstimmung jeder nur einen Abgeordneten.
Martin vielen vielen Dank.
Ja sehr gerne.
Danke und weiter so ciao ciao das war doch jetzt echt ne schöne schöne Erfahrungsbericht oder.
Auf jeden Fall also mir hat das jetzt sehr imponiert und vor allem weil,
diesen in der Ruhe liegt die Kraft das merkt man immer wieder und wenn man Diskussionen führen will mit Leuten,
wann wie man so schön sagt man muss ja auch da abholen wo Sie gerade stehen und dann kann ich aber davon ausgehen dass die eigene Position automatisch irgendwie gilt nur wenn man sie besonders laut und intensiv.
Und es fallen auch so ein anderer Ansatz ist nicht so die Lohmühle Lösung sondern Moser Geschichte sondern ich gehe daran ich rufe da an ich überzeugt die und eben auch so eine so eine Uhr demokratische
Art damit umzugehen und das sind wir auch so ein bisschen Hoffnung wieder mit schwingt also.
Ja das merke ich das merke ich tatsächlich in in also,
wenn man jetzt so über Jahre politische Bewegung und Netzpolitik begleitet dann ist das natürlich immer
ja schon bisschen interessant sich glaube ich mein hätten wir mal so schön so schön Protest gehabt gegen Staatstrojaner ne wir wie diese Wellen kommen dass es immer irgendwie überraschend und wenn die dann aber wenn du dann mal so eine Weile hast wie jetzt hier Artikel 13 großes großes Thema ja viele Demonstrationen,
dann hast du gleichzeitig auch immer leider so etwas,
soll ich mal unschöne Rand Phänomene ne jetzt gar nicht sagen dass das alles ganz unschön ist aber da der kommt natürlich dann auch so Sachen hoch wie das eben vielleicht,
nicht auszuschließen ist dass einige Leute die da anrufen vielleicht nicht ganz so differenziert und ruhig wieder Martin sind,
ja das passiert dann nimmt man in Kauf und ziemlich das ist auch völlig notwendig dass das auch in Kauf zu nehmen und das ist eben auch die Breite dessen wie Menschen darauf reagieren und so weiter,
es ist natürlich immer bedenklich und das habe ich tatsächlich jetzt so seit eigentlich erst seit der Demo am,
53 dieses dieses Gefühl so ein bisschen entwickelter.
Also V III in Berlin vor der CDU-Zentrale.
Komme gleich komme gleich noch mal zu dass ich so das Gefühl hatte,
vielleicht Verfahren sich hier gerade die Fronten und wir nehmen uns eigentlich beiden Seiten die Möglichkeit da noch irgendwie,
gesichtswahrend aus der Nummer raus zu kommen was am Ende dazu führt dass es in so einer griechischen Tragödie vielleicht ausartet ne nur so ein Gefühl ich sage das nur deshalb weil ich gestern auch eine sehr positive Erfahrung gemacht habe bei den rocketbeans,
das ist eine eine YouTube
live Sender im Prinzip die senden vier unserer nicht immer live Assi Sendung wurde sicher auch schon letzte Sendung angekündigt hatte aufgezeichnet aber dann sehr zeitnah,
gesendet auf YouTube und die streamen glaube ich 24/7 und hatten da auch so gesagt ok wlan jetzt mal ein den Robin Blase der war mit dabei dieser change.org Petition hat die da auch übergeben,
mit den 4,7 Millionen Unterzeichnungen
und Christopher Borgmann ein Mädchen Rechtsanwalt der sich in dem diese ganze nur wer rechts
Bereich sehr stark auskennt und darin in allen Richtungen auch Erfahrung gemacht hatte er sowohl für sehr große Rechteverwerter als auch für kleinere ist der.
Juristisch eben als Anwalt aktiv und ich war auch da und dann haben wir so ein bisschen in Ruhe mal anderthalb Stunden darüber über die Ansprüche und so weiter,
bisschen sachlicher berichtet und ich seh so in den YouTube Kommentaren wo ich ja normalerweise gar nicht rein schaue aber da habe ich gedacht dann gucke ich mal auch tatsächlich das,
auch in den YouTube Kommentaren gesagt wird so oh ja schön so eine sachliche Debatte über dieses Thema war jetzt echt mal angenehm.
Scheint wohl nicht überall auf YouTube so zu sein.
Ist auch ein ganz schön langes Format ne anderthalb Stunden ich dachte was geht gar nicht.
Kommt durch die ganzen Werbeunterbrechung nein.
Hast du den ordentlich Werbung für unseren Podcast.
Ich habe einen LRP T-Shirt angezogen und ansonsten überzeuge ich dir einfach nur dich komplett.
Das stimmt unsere Freundlichkeit und überhaupt deinen Charme und alle.
Freundlichkeit charme Aussehen contents.
Ja das ist ja irre.
Rundum-Paket.
Ja bescheiden.
Das zeichnet dich aus.
Aber kommen wir dass dass das nur am Rande da wär also auch gesehen es gibt jetzt auch wirklich wieder ein Bedarf das ganze ein bisschen zu versachlichen.
Jetzt kommt ein bisschen wollten wir mit dir zurückschauen Markus auf die sich das bisher entwickelt hat wollen wir beim Amt Demo Demonstration zweiten dritten noch mal kurz anfangen.
Eichengrill also wenn man sich jetzt so isst man so dieses kann den ganzen Protest anschaut dann hat es ja so eine Dynamik von es gab irgendwann 2018 Proteste wo ein paar Leute draußen auf der Straße waren eh
sehr wenige und dann ist das im Netz groß geworden der Petition und jetzt und und dann immer mehr
Aktivität online Protest und jetzt ist es auf die Straße geshoppt und zwar durch die zwei Initialen Demonstration in Köln auf der
aber der ersten um die 1500-2000 Leute waren und dann ungefähr zweieinhalb 34.000 bei der zweiten Demo und dann gabs eben die Demonstration am 2.
März in Berlin und da hat sich so ein bisschen der Funke medial übergesprungen den Köln da war irgendwie Torsten kleinz von heißer als einzige journal.
Der einzige ne.
Berichtet irgendwie ich habe noch einen Stream geschaut und auch darüber dann was geschrieben aber eigentlich war dann doch nicht viel und dann
immer noch wieder eine typische Reaktion auf was man über bei sozialen Bewegung auch sieht so die beachten uns alle nicht da passiert nichts mehr werden nicht gehört und so
und da hat war so bisschen diese Demo in Berlin,
habe ich den Wendepunkt wo eben auf einmal heute da ist es ZDF war da mit Aldi und und,
komplett einmal durch die Presse bundesweit durch und jetzt ist das Thema gesetzt man kann vielleicht noch zu so einem,
Beobachtung auch was was was irgendwie auch typisch bei sozialen Bewegung ist ist so eine Tag der das,
dass die Gegenseite quasi Öl ins Feuer gießt unbewusst also dass der ist hat die EU-Kommission die Guardia seit der Mob dann wird ihr Sideboard ihr seid instrumentalisiert
und dann hat eben diese soziale Bewegung das sehr schön eigentlich sich angeeignet das ist also auch passiert bei Protest da nicht auch immer
was ich Erdogan sagt ihr seid capulcu ihr seid irgendwie Plünderer die Leute sagen wir sind kaputt und das gleiche
Domain war ihr Sideboard und jetzt wir sind die Bots,
das dann kam noch dieses Werbevideo was ist Europäische Parlament getwittert hatte also man den Eichen Account von dem man Neutralität erwartet.
Jajaja dieses Video.
Das mündet endet dann nach dieser Demo am 2. März den Sitz noch da rein das auf einmal die Manfred Weber das der Fraktionsvorsitzende der,
europäischen konservativen im Parlament gesagt er ja tu das Netz ist der Aktionstag am 23 März jetzt legen wir das mal nach vorne um die Presse zu umgehen.
Man muss dazu sagen Manfred Weber ist so ein bisschen die designierte EU Commission's Kandidat zumindest sehr konservativen mit durchaus guten Chancen ist auch zu werden als nicht irgendjemand.
Genau also da wird dann der Versuch des vorzuverlegen,
dann gab es ja dir das was jetzt dann quasi eine Demonstration also spontane oder rechts kurzfristig organisierte Demo ist die Einheit von 24 Stunden auf die Beine gestellt wurden und da waren dann,
am 5. März vor CDU zentralen und in fünf verschiedenen Städten,
zwischen 5 und 7 einhalb tausend Leute wäre ich auf der auf der Straße die da irgendwie wütend hingegangen sind und das hat jetzt nur noch mal glaube ich noch mehr,
noch mehr das den Protest befeuert und es ging ja dann dann kam am Abend ist dann Weber zurückgerudert und hat gesagt ja nicht machen wir doch nicht ist wahr dann aber doch noch auf der Tagesordnung,
und dann sind obwohl diesen zurückrudern sind am nächsten Tag noch mal in Hannover und in Hamburg noch mal insgesamt in noch mal jeweils 500 auf die Straße gegangen die gesagt haben ja sonst egal ob das jetzt zurück wir gehen trotzdem auf die Straße Alter,
da merkt man es jetzt Momentum dafür
die soziale Bewegung oder für die für diese internet Bewegung da irgendwas zu reißen hatte da ist jetzt irgendwie echt Musik drin das vielleicht doch noch auch zu Clip.
Da bin ich mir ja wahrscheinlich schon also ja es ist auf jeden Fall wenn dann ist es jetzt zu kippen.
Das brauche ich glaube ich brauche noch viel mehr um das zu kippen aber,
ich glaube dass diese Idee diese Protestbewegung auf jeden Fall auf gerade auf einem guten Weg ist irgendwie dass das Thema,
in Medien stattfindet das ist erklärt wird überhaupt nicht an das ist ja sowas sperriges Upload Filter Artikel 13 wer soll sich ein dafür interessieren das war vor ein paar Wochen waren das irgendwie ein paar Nerds und die YouTube Szene irgendwie.
Panurge Hallo wer bestimmt wir haben also also wir im Sinne von netzpolitik.org.
Wenn schon lange.
Netzpolitik haben sie begleitet im Prinzip Seite ist Aufgaben.
Gerade eben bleibt über upload-filter schreiben wir schon glaube ich seit Jahren aber das Thema hat jetzt irgendwie ist jetzt nicht irgendwie eine Breitenwirkung hat das entfaltet.
Nee nee überhaupt nicht ich hatte ich bin auch ganz ehrlich hatte.
Streckenweise habe ich dann auch für gesagt,
Thomas machst du das Thema noch meine oder können wir Julia noch mal rein holen ist wichtig aber das wurde auch solange rauf und runter diskutiert ein ich schon dass sich persönlich dachte so jetzt muss das auch mal hinter müssen uns mal loswerden ja,
und gleichzeitig hab.
Naja ist ja Ende März soweit.
Genau und gleichzeitig habe ich aber auch gedacht das wird dass das die Idee eine so beknackt ist dass das schon irgendwie gut gehen wird ja ich hätte jetzt nicht gedacht dass das noch an an diesem Punkt eskaliert werden muss.
Ich meine jetzt ist die Sache so ich meine das Ding ist nach dem Trilog schon ne also da nach dem Produkt ist doch der Bund nur die Softwarepatente gekippt eigentlich ist es,
nur Formsache dass das
EU-Parlament dann nach diesem ganzen Verhandlungsprozess dann noch zustimmt also das ist so die härteste Nuss die man außerparlamentarisch knacken kann ist nach dem Trilog noch eine Richtlinie
kippen und das ist jetzt der Versuch der da gemacht wird also das ist schon mehr wär schon geschichtsträchtig das zu kippen es ist sicherlich sehr schwer.
Geschichtsträchtig ist sehr schön wie siehst du denn.
Also denke man kann das nicht fahr nicht verheimlichen das braucht doch gar nicht dass das,
jetzt bei diesem Demonstrationen schon einige Menschen sind.
Wo ich will das halt schreiben die gerade so ihren Politisierung im Moment erleben na die sind jetzt in so einem Alter wo sie,
wahrscheinlich irgendwo ich sag jetzt mal zwischen 16 und 23 oder sowas Nervosität zu merken ok Kaster gibt es zum ersten Mal ein politisches Thema und einen politischen Vorgang über den ich,
aus welchem gut informiert bin den ich jetzt auch lange genug vielleicht verfolgt habe und wo ich merke da läuft was schief und er läuft ja auch was schief ja da wie hier mit dem,
Protest umgegangen wird Widerlegungen ne Taktiererei ein und sind Prozesse die üblicherweise trägt ein Mensch der nicht richtig,
politisch interessiert es an einem Thema sonst nicht mitbekommt die bekommen wir ja auch bei anderen Themen die für uns jetzt vielleicht nicht so unser Fachgebiet sind auch nicht mit und jetzt hast Du hier blöd,
jüngere Menschen designare wir all diese upload-filter nicht wir kriegen jetzt bei unserem täglichen YouTube schauen regelmäßig davon zu hören da ist irgendwie ein Skandal nach dem anderen Lied reicht und dann stehen die,
am Abend ist 53 halt bei der an der CDU-Zentrale.
Wind und Regen Wetter Kälte genau da musst schon wütend sein also.
Beleuchteten demoschilder Ninja und,
und dann irgendwie wird sein heißt nie wieder CDU dann stehen die an und Millionen,
ihr den Stinkefinger Nunchuk zeigen alle nicht nichtig wegen einer und das war das im ersten Moment habe ich gedacht so oyoyoy das habe ich aber lange nicht mehr gesehen geil aber dann natürlich auch so ein bisschen dieses,
diese Sorge unbestimmte sorge dich nicht so erfüllt hat so dass der fast nicht ein noch viel mehr ärgert,
als der Inhalt dieser Debatte wird sie Copyright Reform ist oder nicht sondern wie diesen Menschen,
der Politikbetrieb jetzt vorgestellt wird ne so hallo wir sind die CDU und so gehen wir mit euch um,
und das macht mir Sorgen ich meine dass die Wendy sagen nie wieder CDU finde ich sehr witzig weil da irgendwie im Prinzip drin steht das,
sind Stunde dass die schon mal CDU gewählt haben ich habe jetzt Anhaltspunkte das von von vielen dieser Leute auch auf YouTube wahrscheinlich
einige noch nie einen Wahllokal von innen gesehen haben da herrschen sehr wilde Vorstellungen davon dass der in die eine Urne für jede Partei stünde oder soll Fasnet der ist noch viel Potenzial,
und das natürlich werden die nicht CDU wählen hoffentlich nicht bitte liebe merkt euch das.
Die werden wahrscheinlich auch nicht SPD wählen.
Wie werden die SPD bin.
Veilchen.
Und das finde ich auch gut aber was lernen die über dem politischen,
Prozess ja wenn wenn du mich da andere Parteien sind die letztendlich sagen das ist alles die da oben machen was sie wollen das sind alles Betrüger die sind die sind alle von den großen Firmen gekauft und will lieber uns wir haben ne einfache Lösung,
genau die können jetzt im Prinzip diese Protestgruppen
eventuell relativ einfach abgrasen und deswegen war mir das auch so wichtig heute hier mit dem Martin zu sprechen
und Martins Erfahrung da auch widerzuspiegeln das soll nicht heißen dass der Protest nicht in Ordnung ist und nicht legitimiert wird oder sonst was dann der Wasserpfeife wie sich hier die CDU,
mal wieder im politischen
Prozess verhält das ist einfach ja ein Angriff auf die Demokratie und zwar deshalb weil sie den dem der Demokratie das Fundament,
entzieht nämlich Menschen die an sie glauben und den Grund haben an die Demokratie zu glauben.
Er sich das ist was da passiert also diese Umgangsweise das ist wirklich denkbar schlecht und irgendwie hat so eine Thermografie
die verachtende Nummer auf der anderen Seite sieht man ja dass diese Protestbewegung an Abgeordnete die für die für sie kämpfen ob das jetzt Julia Räder sind ist oder auch an
geht doch ein SPD-Abgeordnete auch dass sie sich sehr freuen und dann auch irgendwie dann glaube nicht mal das Beste outcome
wäre also die eine Variante ist die Leute wenden sich in das geht jetzt schief und dann kommt Artikel 13 und die Urheberrechtsreform durch und wenden sich enttäuscht ab und sah, wie die mit umgehen,
bitte bessere outcome Beere Hey guck mal wir können haben die wir haben die unter Druck gesetzt wir können uns verbünden wir können uns vernetzen ist es cool wir können auf die Straße Demo ausmachen Spaß also da ist ja auch einen ist ne
ich kann was verändern ich will halt jetzt eine andere Partei die nicht für das Ding gestimmt hat,
sehr schön wenn daneben ein Positiv demokratische outcome ist doch nicht meine Enttäuschungen und in die Richtung hatte,
das ist liegt auch in der Verantwortung von Leuten die die da Protest organisieren das in diese Richtung auch irgendwie zu kommunizieren,
damit er nicht irgendwie was was was was so einen so einen Schrott rauskommt und antidemokratische der dann so Wasser auf den Mühlen von rechts
polisten ist aber ich würde es ja dann dass er sie das erstmal noch nicht als Problem aber muss das Mitdenken.
Wie alt ist ein Problem nicht nur als Gefahr ich hoffe natürlich dass das diese Proteste jetzt,
ihre Wirkung zeigen und das dass da irgendwie am Ende was versöhnliches bei rauskommt das wäre wirklich auch dass er dann wiederum starkes Signal,
auch wenn aber wie das so ist Signale im starkes.
Dann und ja oder
nein am Ende nach Dubai das ist da wird jetzt nicht einen Kompromiss geben weil das Ding ist aus verhandelt und es gibt ich kann jetzt nicht sagen ich nehme es dir upload-filter raus und dann wird das gemacht sondern dass am Ende wird jetzt über Ja oder Nein entschieden und deswegen
ist es halt natürlich schwierig weil er wird jetzt nicht irgendwie noch mal einen neuen Kompromiss,
das ist der Kompromiss wäre beziehen Sitz zurück und dann machen das dann neu quasi oder wird abgelehnt und dann wird neu verhandelt.
Aber halt nicht mehr in dieser Legislatur also damit ist halt das gesamte Projekt komplett gestorben was natürlich für das Parlament oder Samen auf den gesamten europäischen politischen Diskurs,
ein riesen fail Verena das drückt natürlich hier noch mal
extra mit rein aber das wäre dann auch sag mir mal etwas was man ganz gut mitnehmen könnte ja das eben die Details auch wirklich
wichtig sind und ich stehe da also auf dem Punkte und na ja dann lass es einfach komplett sein und nächste mal wissen wir es machen
naja wenn dann auch ohne Julia Räder was ist bisschen schade
aber wir sind ja auch bereit für andere Shootingstar könnt ihr vielleicht für mich der ich im Wesentlichen jetzt während dieser ganzen Demo Phase im Ausland weilte vielleicht noch mal kurz.
Ja da auch mal ein bisschen demonstrieren können Tim Schulstreik oder was hast du.
Habe ich auch bin dein Balkon rauf und runter gelaufen und.
Hast du einen #not 13 Uhr aus dem Fenster gehängt wenigstens.
Algerien aber da passiert derzeit viele Sachen da das irgendwie das ganze auch sichtbare wird und in die Öffentlichkeit geht und das Ganze also ich glaube da sind jetzt in vielen Punkten
überall Leute diesen diesen jetzt politisiert und motiviert und und die die wollen was machen und die dich wann,
es gab diese diese in in in Recke diese diese diese diese politischer Aschermittwoch Veranstaltungen.
Das war das war eigentlich nur so ein kurzer Hinweis dir ich müsste jetzt noch mal genau schauen auf Twitter von welchem von wem ich da den Hinweis bekommen hatte aber es gab im Prinzip so hier.
Manfred Weber.
Weber der gerade dabei zu der Zeit wo er gerade versuchte die Abstimmung irgendwie im Nebel zu verziehen woanders hinzulegen war jetzt am politischen Aschermittwoch also gestern Abend in Recke so,
wo ist Michael keine Ahnung bei Osnabrück so und.
Ganz kurze also nur dass hier ein folgerichtig hinbekommen also es gab den Aufruf I demovarin Köln.
Genau das ist,
erst die Übergabe dieser 5 Millionen oder 4,8 Millionen Unterschriften also der Peter Petition ist auf dem Weg zur größten Petition,
und dann hat Barleben sie nicht dagegen gestimmt nur die SPD hat gerade verstehe euch sehr und alles schon ist ja schon irgendwie schwierig aber bestimmt doch dafür,
so kennt man ein bisschen von der SPD halt,
und dann gab es die Demos in in Köln die auch ganz kurzfristig organisiert wurden zwei Stück hintereinander und die wurden jedesmal größer.
Dann kam die Berliner Demo.
Die Berliner Auftakt Demo und dann die die spontan Demos wiederum als Reaktion auf diese verschiebe rei.
Genau und was jetzt so passiert dass wir pflegen gerade bei Netzpolitik ne eine Liste noch in der Karte und eine Liste mit mit allen Demos und momentan,
Rasseln die Demo Saga nur so Rheinelbe machen Leipzig auch noch und Potsdam und Bam Bam Bam und jetzt auch vor dem 23 schon also da ist jetzt
das irgendwer passiert jetzt was es gibt schon am nächsten Wochenende wird's am Samstag Samstag am 9. März gibt's ja eben auch schon wieder drei Demos in top magdeburg-leipzig
und in Kassel und da ist jetzt da ist etwas in Bewegung geraten oder entstehen jetzt überall Aktion Demos Leute
tut sich zusammen und das geht so ein bisschen von diesem von Köln und und Berlin von Großstädten noch weg in kleinere Städte und ich glaube das ist schon das was eine Bewegung Kennzeichen was jetzt halt noch fehlt ist quasi
ist halt das in in europäischen stell.
Und würdest du sagen dass das jetzt noch unsere Kernnetz politische Zähne ist die das treibt oder ist es dann schon mehr von YouTube aus.
Na ich nehme ich habe das schon.
Ist das egal jetzt jetzt ist der Moment wo das egal ist also da wo es eine Bewegung ist.
Egal wer es macht aber wer macht.
Na ja ich glaube das interessante fand ich so wenn man sich so die Berliner Demo angeschaut hat
das eben da der treffen komplett unterschiedliche Szenen aufeinander der ist natürlich diese die altehrwürdige Netzgemeinde der CCC und digitale Gesellschaft und irgendwie das auch schon Logo und die ganzen Ergebnisse diese diese ganze
für dich schon was ist der Blues Band der der von Grundrechte und freie Gesellschaft freies Internet die sind da auch am Start die beobachtet erstelle und dann gibt es eine komplett,
unabhängig,
von von diesen oder gibt's auch wenig Verknüpfungspunkte da sie die kennen sich auch nicht und jetzt trifft es zusammen und da trifft das zusammen auf einer Demo und das ist halt
schon schon spannend dass da irgendwie jetzt verschiedene Generationen wie einen diesen eher so die über 30 40 jährigen oder irgendwie also sollte eine institutionalisierte,
Angy aus und und Proteste Bewegung oder die schon lange auch immer wieder sowas gemacht hat und Leute die ist erste Mal auf der Straße sind und es trifft aufeinander oder sind auch unterschiedliche Demonstration Skulpturen also da kannst Auseinandersetzungen
Berlin darüber UTM Techno gespielt wenn wir in Berlin und weiß er weder Demo wird irgendwie Techno gespielt also.
Froh dass dass das war das ähnlich also die selber den Berliner Demonstrierenden Zähne ist ja froh dass sie nicht mehr den ganzen Tag durch die durch die Länder Maschinen muss und Parolen skandieren.
Aber genau das war ja der Wunsch von den Leuten dieses verdammte konnten uns mit wurden wecke passt quasi wir habt ihr unsere Parolen.
Schalte an jetzt am uploadfilter weil weil hier Musik lief und wir können die jetzt nicht monetarisieren oder so naja das.
Nebeneffekt sein.
Das ist auch natürlich ärgerlich wenn ihr die Video Live Streams nicht monetäre sehen können aber ist auf jeden Fall auch ein witziges Phänomen dass ich jetzt ist das Prinzip die Livestreams über diese DUO daran scheitern dass YouTube nun schon uploadfilter hat
Spiele die Musik die da läuft erkennen und gleichzeitig natürlich finde ich das auch sehr natürlich kann man sagen,
Hey Musik ist kein Inhalt Musik ist nur die Musik in dem Fall dient ja im weitesten Sinne,
dem Zweck nicht nur sichtbar zu sein sondern auch
zuhören irgendwie eine Form von Aufmerksamkeit zu erregen und vor allem finde ich hat die Musik die sehr wichtige Symbol der Friedlichkeit ja die signalisiert hier sind friedliche Menschen hier sind hier ist,
positiver walbrach.
Sag es Loveparade ondemand Friede Freude aller.
Bis wann er war bei der war gab sie kriegt das ist doch kein seriöser Protest aber ist jetzt.
Also ich nicht na ja aber das ist nicht so spannend und ich dachte gerade wenn so eine soziale wird so eine Bewegung du Brot hast du wieder beim Stehen ist da gibt's halt Lernprozesse und Ezra,
dann Wander und die kennen nicht die Kultur der anderen und dann ich finde es spannend und daraus kann ja dann nur gegenseitig von mir kann man echt nur was lernen.
Machen uns zusammen machen.
Ich fand diese Debatten sehr interessant vor allem weil die,
auch auf die Weise geführt wurden wie die Leute es gewöhnt sind
die alten die sagen wir sind hier großes Bündnis wir sehen zu dass wir mit allen zusammen arbeiten wir sehen zu dass wir,
Youtuber die sich gegen dieses Ding aussprechen
auf die Bühne holen wir strecken die den die Hand entgegen und dann die diese neuen Leute die ihre eigene Kultur haben und diese Kultur ist eben wenn mir irgendwas nicht gefällt dann machen Youtube-Video und rannte,
egal ob das jetzt mein Freund meine Verbündeten sind oder sonst was und trete den fünf Mal ins Kreuz und sag alles was die gemacht haben vanscheidt war scheiße es muss jetzt anders sein ja das Hitzeblech für kulturelle Unterschiede.
Ein bisschen lernen.
Die die ich dann sehr überraschend finde die aber auch wenn man sie am beobachtet,
tatsächlich auch zeigen so diskutieren die halt mir würde nicht in den Sinn kommen im Prinzip Menschen die ich auf,
der richtigen Seite der Macht ein Ordner hier übermäßig,
immer längeren Ding irgendwie zu kritisieren ja da kann man eine solidarische Kritik üben interessanterweise merke ich dann nicht,
kann ja YouTube nicht so gut gucken weil mich das zu sehr ablenken kommen die Mehrzahl arbeiten dass die,
die diskutieren dann über ihre YouTube-Videos ne oder nee Präferenz ihr die sich gegenseitig und dann kommt irgendwann einer der dann wieder solch man in dem Fall,
wozu Güte sagt das war hier der wie heißt der Simon will kann das sein heißt ja so der war der auch auf der Demo.
Das Video Erde diesen song gemacht.
Für den song gemacht hat und T-Shirts T-Shirts gemacht weil der vaginal Beträge gespendet hat hat er irgendwie seinen Shitstorm für bekommen hat sich dann.
Außer eigenen Zähne.
Aus der eigene Zähne und fand ich auch da hat er dann auch das fand ich wiederum beeindrucken wird nicht souverän reagiert und hat gesagt ja hier kommen dass vermisst
na das war dass wir spenden natürlich sämtliche Gewinne nachdem wir alle unsere Löhne und die Probezeit hat jetzt
nee aber die diskutieren so was für uns wiederum und ich würde mich jetzt mal zu der,
vielleicht etwas länger schon im Bereich aktiven Gruppe zählen,
dann wiederum neu ist ne weil wenn wenn man jetzt in diesen Bewegungs Organisation ist dann glaub man sich natürlich hinter den Kulissen an und nicht vor versammelter YouTube Mannschaft der.
Nee das ist mein interessant an den ganzen.
Wie kommt da trotzdem auf einen grünen Zweig miteinander finde ich auch interessant.
Wenn es in der und das krasse an der Erde an dieser Demo wenn man sich das so anschaut ist natürlich das sind für diese Reichweiten sind halt also damit organisiert die altehrwürdigen
LG aus quasi die Demo
und dann aber die die die Mobilisierung kam er quasi zu 80 % wahrscheinlich über YouTube und die Reichweite dessen Namen dabei ihr habt ihr noch nie gehört aber die haben dreimal so viele Follower wir Markus Beckedahl ja,
ist es ist halt interessant oder das ist in Reichweite des Livestreams da sind 15.000 20.000 Leute im Livestream und am Abend Hans 200.000 Leute an die Demo sie angeguckt,
und das ist halt auch so krass allgemein Reichweiten mäßig ist das da können wir halten und könnten noch mal was davon abschneiden.
Absolut interessant ja ich finde das aber auch ganz dann hast du natürlich da dieses da Phänomene so ein bisschen ne,
das sind eben ich will das gar nicht werden ich wollte nur so ein bisschen schildern wie halt so Dinge wirken ja an der jeweils anderen Seite ich hätte mir nie vorstellen können dass sich das jemand ernsthaft,
böse dagegen.
Gutes tiert das auf einer Demonstration auch Musik gespielt wird und das ging ja soweit dass da die Braten Abgabe haben gelernt nie wieder Musik auf dich muss.
Bitte 3000 likes.
Verbot für Suppen meine Güte so wir haben an anderer Stelle in Berlin wurde lange dafür gearbeitet die Protestkultur mal ein bisschen,
angenehmer zu gestalten für diejenige die sehen müssen und diejenigen die da mitmachen müssen gut ihr Zeug wieder anders sein,
tut mir ja auch nicht weh also ist ja auch in Ordnung.
Das ist ja auch ich bin so Protestbewegung das ist im Fluss oder passieren und das ist auch richtig dass alle Seiten da ihr Ding wie sie demonstrieren und protestieren wollen
bekommen und das mit ich denke das ist dann das müssen sie hat,
die man nicht kennenlernen und auch Kontakt nicht mehr das ist ja auch gut sich zu verletzen und mal gucken wie das weitergeht aber es ist auf jeden Fall auch echt spannend da hinzugehen und sich das anzuschauen oder mit zu demonstrieren und zu sehen auch okay so demonstrieren andere und so ist das
also das ist es auch
ist es für ich finde sowas kulturell auch immer spannend Protest eigentlich schau mir alles mögliche an Protesten an für das macht auf jeden Fall auch Spaß.
Also auf die auf jeden Fall interessante interessante Phänomene vor allem da wo ich sie nicht erwartet hätte ja also ich hätte jetzt nicht also die,
Diskussionen die es da gab die hätte ich jetzt nicht erwartet und wie gesagt ich habe das teilweise als ziemlich,
der unsolidarisch erstmal gewertet bis ich dann irgendwie gesehen habe dass diese diese Youtuber Kultur die kennen sich da irgendwie auch außen untereinander aus nadi,
müssen dann dekorieren Sie natürlich auch irgendwie um Aufmerksamkeit und wer hat als erstes die Idee ne dann muss eben wie eine Idee die andere schon eine Woche vorher hatten
noch mal neu erfunden werden und mit dem anderen Hashtag um zu gucken wer jetzt hier den wird sich größere Youtuber ist und Sonne diese monetarisierungs Dinger die da mit rein spielt für mich natürlich auch immer sehr,
beachtenswert,
und insgesamt ein sehr sehr spannender Lernprozess ich frage mich welchen Lernprozess aber jetzt so diese YouTube Szene denn das jetzt mein also diese YouTube sehen,
welchen Lernprozess die mitnehmen weil die jetzt zum,
in meinem Dafürhalten zum ersten Mal auch merken so voll ich kann hier nicht nur like und Klick und kauft noch einen Schuh oder sowas sondern ich kann auch Leute gehen auf die Straße.
Und setzen setzen sich für ein politisches,
Interesse 1 das bin ich mal gespannt wie sich das weiterentwickelt wie oft ihnen das gelingt auch diese Mobilisierung zu machen.
Nein das ist ein Lernprozess das ist ja auch ich hatte ein Artikel geschrieben wie macht man eigentlich Demos und irgendwie auch so das muss ja auch alles lernen und dann schaue ich habe immer so ein Livestream oder in danach angeschaut von der Demo orlando diese Polizei hier die Nettetal aggressiv und ich dachte so okay ich war schon oft auf der Nationen,
bitte alles Visite total wenig Polizei dir alles total locker keine Helme keine Knüppel kein Pfeffer alles ist
alles easy und du denkst du okay aber das sind einfach Protest Erfahrung wenn ich erstmal da bin und sehende martialisch auftretende Polizei die mir ein bisschen da abgebrüht ist
Hamburg vorkommen aber ich erzähl erstmal die Firma Norderstedt und irgendwie so eine neue Ordnungsmacht gegenüber und es sieht brutal aus und die also das ist alles Dinge die die muss man lernen und ich finde Stapelsessel
generell ist es gut diese demokratische Erfahrung von Protest zu machen die Erfahrung aufzumachen mit diesem,
Beginn des machen Spontandemo Sports EDU zentralen und dann ruht Andy zurück das ist eine gewonnene kleine Schlachter in diesen ganzen Ding dessen Wissen gut erfahren dass ist Selbstermächtigung und das ist das kann man nur mitnehmen und wieder anwenden im besten Fall.
Dann glaube ich bisher noch auf eine Sache eingehen nehme ich das hier ja wirklich einen clash of cultures ist in dieser politischen Auseinandersetzung gerade schon kurz,
erwähnt dieser politischer Aschermittwoch in Recke Recke ist irgendwo bei Osnabrück da haben die sich ein Bierzelt hingestellt für dich das für die CDU gehört und haben da ein,
politischen Aschermittwoch gemacht und da war eben auch der Manfred Weber und ich wurde irgendwie auf Twitter darauf hingewiesen dann habe ich irgendwie getwittert hier wer den Manfred Weber gerade nicht erreicht,
das liegt daran dass der auf Deutschlandtournee ist man kann ihn z.b. am Mittwochabend in Recke vielleicht treffen um mit ihm noch mal über die,
Copyright Reform zu sprechen.
Das hat dann tatsächlich Leute gemacht.
Ich gemacht und zwar nicht zu wenige und würde ihr wieso von 50 personen berichtet die nicht alle in das Zelt gelassen wurden weil diese Security dann irgendwann auch gemerkt hat was da los ist
Eiterfeld.
Die zu jung waren heute.
Junge der einzige der einzige unter 50-Jährige der in der CDU vertreten ist ist dieser am Tor oder wie der heißt ne Dessert.
Der sieht aber nicht so aus als ob er.
Wie sicher sind R40Li lacht die da angekommen sind die hatten noch Lebensfreude in sich und das war natürlich verdächtigt und die haben dann da.
Klassisch ganz klassisch.
Ja die haben schön gestört das wieso beim grünen Parteitag wenn es um Krieg und Frieden geht so klein dass so ein bisschen wir können mal kurz reinhören ist im Wesentlichen viel Gepfeife aber feiner noch ein paar ganz interessante Kommentar.
Ich komme Tage der CDU live.
Wo Helferlein ja genau.
Wie wird ein.
Ja oder ein anderer.
Wir wollen das hören.
Oh jetzt hat die CDU sauer.
Graubärte ja er sieht wirklich.
Platzende Junge Union la noch.
Also es würde ja Stau diese veranstaltet sieht wirklich aus wie so ein so so so so so.
Wind Wien.
Vollversammlung im Altersheim.
Deaktiviere den den auch die transparente weg und so ne also die reagieren dann ja auch unseren.
Uhr demokratisch Demokrat.
Und im weiteren Verlauf wurde wer dann auch Bericht der Wunder Tech intern die Polizei gerufen wurden die Personalien aufgenommen den Leuten gedroht die Demonstration war nicht angemeldet ne aber das wenn man nicht spontan
Trillerpfeife dabei haben könnten und da sind natürlich dann auch sehr sehr interessante Phänomene,
zu beobachten gewesen.
Das ist gut so was ist gut also vor allem die müssen es auch merken also gerade hier so diese ich weiß was die wart ihr schon auf dem politischen Aschermittwoch.
Nicht so häufig.
Irgendwoher das sind ja neu.
Ich finde das eher der da werden halt irgendwie Witze über Intersexuelle gemacht oder so na das ist jetzt irgendwie so CDU Niveau da hat sich bisher nicht hingezogen.
War jetzt der Karneval.
Achso beim Affe politischer Aschermittwoch ist.
Aschermittwoch ist ja wenn Karneval vorbei ist.
Wird dafür die ihre brandreden halten.
Alles ist ein eigentlich eigentlich ist das so Post Karneval das passt schon alles noch ganz gut daran sind dann alle noch betrunken und dann.
So leicht verkatert.
So leicht verkatert sitzen naja ist auch noch mal richtig drauf.
Letzte letzte Kneipenschlägerei.
Na, dann irgendwie auch mal weitermachen.
Letzte kleine Schlägerei vorm ausnüchtern ja so finde ich auch mal ganz nett und ich finde das,
eigentlich auch ganz schön einfach so also ich würde mir ja wünschen wir niemals die Blöße geben zu müssen bei einer Karnevalsveranstaltung Leute rauswerfen zu müssen und die Bullen zurufen.
Aber mir weitere tempotest geht schon in die Breite des jetzt hier kann ich mein das wovor alle immer Angst haben also
ist der kollektive Aktionen und das ist das was gerade passiert dass Leute einfach selber auch in Aktion treten es gibt nicht also wenn man ich habe mir das echt angeschaut wie das so dann haben wir so
wenn man wer organisiert irgendwann eine Demo organisiert weißt du so von oben ne und jetzt ist so ich mach jetzt eine Demo also es ist so hart zu den Punkten an eine andere Stufe erreicht oder woowcase dreh dich selber in Aktion
und das ist halt also ja das hat hat auf jedes Rad auf jeden Fall Feuer so gerade.
Dann haben wir noch auch am 631 am Mittwoch gehabt in an der CDU-Zentrale in Hannover.
Bin noch in Hannover wo auch in Hannover dann irgendwie 300-500 Leute waren und die tagesschau und dann kam der auch die CDU da glaube ich raus und habe sich dem gestellt
und in Hamburg wurde auch vor der CDU-Zentrale protestiert also es geht dann schon immer auch alles wieder sehr direkte also den Adressaten
auch direkt konfrontieren das ist auch so eine
was man jetzt mehr beobachten kann also dass ich habe diese vorverlegen hat einfach sehr viel Wut ausgelöst weil er so eine Verachtung ausspricht und das ist auch genau die richtige Reaktion darauf zu reagieren und sende nicht mit.
CDU-Zentrale finde ich jetzt auch irgendwie in dankbares bestrahlungs Objekte kümmern schon mal richtig Präsenz zeigen da laufen dann auch die richtigen Leute rein und raus.
Ja leider um die Uhrzeit nicht mehr da lief nur noch bei KPMG Leute rein und raus,
Gigi Stand von oben dran haben entwickelt weil sie dachten der unmittelbare Sturm steht bevor,
das wird ja quasi ich meinte mit dem Untergang des Kapitalismus wird natürlich die KPMG Zentrale in die so ein bisschen was wie die Stasi Gedenkstätte ne und die war natürlich auch so sofort schon am schreddern bye bye.
Wie viel Uhr war denn das dann am Abend oder was oder eher muss man dann halt während der Schule da hingehen.
Ja aber ich meine es war glaube ich so kurzfristig.
Freitag gegen Klima Donnerstag gegen Artikel 13 so.
Okay das war die nächste Eskalation
rufe natürlich ist während der Schulzeit protestieren erhöht den Druck immens weil dann sofort irgendwie die ganze um das ist aber hier die Verletzung der Schulpflicht das kommt eine Regelverletzung rein das ist also wenn man Druck erhöhen will natürlich gutes machen die Klima Leute,
Saatgut mit Friday Friday for future und Monday for Internet da könnte.
Also da ist nicht nett das Essen von,
und soziale bewegungstheorie ist natürlich in den Druck erhöhen das ist immer wichtig wenn man das Ziel erreichen will.
Diese Schuld Proteste werden ja aber kritisiert so sinngemäß mit naja wenn ihr eure Freizeit opfern fürs Hettstadt eure Schulzeit wäre das natürlich irgendwie beeindrucken dann ich habe einen neuen Vorschlag habe ich glaube ich schon mal gemacht,
kita-streik wenn der kleine Kevin morgen sagt ich zieh die Hose nicht an und ich gehe nicht zur Arbeit ja und seine Seite anderen Kita-Kinder machen das auch ne die können das Land lahmlegen,
weil die Eltern dann zu Hause gefangen sind ja die können sagen kein.
Das hat die Frage wie du deine also von einem vierjährigen Kind uploadfilter erklärst jetzt Linus.
Ich versuch mal noch mal einen Termin beim Kita kika zu kriegen.
Aber was für eine verlogene Diskussion weil wir wollen das ja die nicht mit diesen klimastreik Trainerin ja generell über Prozesse und dieses na ja wieso steigt doch bitte außerhalb der Schule ich meine,
Wer streikt denn bitte,
außerhalb der Arbeitszeit also Schweiz und vor allem ich meine es interessant ne Schüler werden ja dann sozusagen auch immer so gesehen mit na ja ihr seid ja noch Schüler.
Lasst euch erstmal alles von uns erklären.
Genau ist Schule und so da habt ihr jetzt mal zu sein und von euch gibt's einfach mal keinen Widerstand weil Widerstand machte dann später wenn wir genug gegen euch in der Hand haben,
da ist dann sozusagen die das Ausscheren aus der Schule.
Das ist das denn.
Der stärkste Ausdruck den man da an der Stelle eigentlich und wie machen kann.
Ja das auf jeden Fall ich mein das erste da der Verletzte der Schüler und die Schülerin die Regel dass man im Schulpflicht hat und sagt das ist mir so viel wert dass ich sein zionen in Kauf nehme
um da zu protestieren das Essen dann das ist eine hat mir eine Form von zivilem Ungehorsam und das also.
Doch gerade Diskussion so auf Twitter ja aber dann steht das ja später in deinem Zeugnis und soll Maisonette.
Wer will dein Zeugnis von der neunten Klasse hat.
Naja erstens irgendwie Wind Wind Wind die Welt sowieso hops geht dann interessiert das erstmal eh kein Bär und zweitens kannst du auch ganz gut sein dass wenn er nicht drin steht dass du gestreikt hast hast du dann vielleicht keine Chance mehr.
Steht Greta dich als erstes an dem.
So sie haben also sie haben also hier nicht weg die Fortschritte im Bereich Klimawandel bestreikt was sind sie denn eigentlich für eine Person.
So
dann haben wir noch glaube ich muss ganz kurz erwähnt werden dieses Artikel 13 video des Europaparlaments das da ist seit Julia Reda ein bisschen hinterher recherchiert und.
Die Mame sind sicher dass er auf dem Norbert Blüm Alter das Europaparlament,
die Rente ist sicher die Mame sind sicher also das ist der Bundestag Bundestag Bundestag die versuchen immer möglich so distanziert wir mehrere Parteien am Start,
mit diskutierte wird kann ich die Positionen und hier wird irgendwie
Video gezeigt was wirklich nur die Positionen der Urheberrechts Lobby zeigt keine Gegenposition wird nicht gesagt dass es noch nicht durch ist auch so so so das ist jetzt hier gemachte Sache.
Unter dem Twitter-Account des Europaparlaments sich mal das hat ja.
Europaparlament deinem sind sicher die Meinungsfreiheit wird nicht berührt es geht um eine faire Vergütung der Urheber hier erfährst du mehr zu Copyright Richtlinie und dann hast du es da alle die wissen.
Werbevideo Wort fange dann so eine urheberrechtsfreie Sation irgendwie mit Luftballons protestiert und in verschiedenen Landes fahren also das ist ein komplett das ist ein Lied ein sehr einseitiges Video und da hat jede Räder das Wort Zusatz.
Ekel hat jetzt festgestellt dass wurde produziert von der Jones France press,
ich würde jetzt sagen agence French Press,
die Katze dieses Video produziert ja in Auftrag und die hat auch schon irgendwelche newspaper verteilt am.
Was ist die Nachrichtenagentur AFP ne also die.
Die Nachrichtenagentur AFP.
Liebe Artikel 11 der auch über der natürlich sehr daran interessiert ist ne dass das der dcsnippets die Links monetarisiert werden.
Genau und die hat auch schon irgendwie.
Eine also die hat eine lobbyagentur mit einer Kampagne beauftragt und mischt quasi die ganze Zeit ihre eigene Tätigkeit,
mit dieser Lobbyarbeit hat also auch schon irgendwie so eine eine Lobby newspaper verkauft verteilt,
wo dann irgendwie drin steht ja hier Urheberrecht eine Frage von Leben und Tod weil das natürlich nicht mit nicht geringerem PartOS zu vermitteln ist,
und geht da also auch sehr sehr amüsant mit um und all sowas ist natürlich der Twitter-Account des Europaparlaments.
Also ich habe bei dem hinterher telefoniert ich habe dann die Pressestelle angerufen und nachgefragt und dann wollte erstmal gar nicht offiziell sagen also nur hinter also nur Hintergrund nur und so bestimmend aber nicht irgendwie sagen und haben das später gab da war aber alles
ist alles rechtens ist vollkommen normal was wir gemacht haben also war auch eine harte Ansage.
Das ja grundsätzlich schon auch so ein bisschen ja weil ist ja klar dass die und unter Umständen Teile ihrer Medien davon
an andere von anderen bauen lassen ja wird es dir Test der Bundestag sagt er wir brauchen wir der Bundeszentrale für politische Bildung dafür braucht man ein Erklärvideo zu XY jetzt beauftragen wir irgendwie.
Zentrum für politische Schönheit.
Politische Schönheit können wir gleich noch was zu jemanden hier so hallo VW könnten Sie uns das mit den.
Dieselfilter noch mal erklären.
Noch mal erklären wir gehen den Geld dafür dass ihr jetzt ein schönes Video machen für unser Twitter das geht natürlich nicht und das sind alles so ganz katastrophale,
ganz katastrophale Vorgänge haben wir es denn jetzt mit dem mit den Upload filtern und dem Artikel 13 und der Copyright Direktive.
Ich schon einmal mal sehen was die nächsten Wochen was passiert es gibt überall Informationen wo man sich an den Sachen beteiligen kann und wir bleiben da auch dran an dem Thema gucken was da,
passiert.
Und vor allem sei die Martin und.
Ruft sie an der tatsächlichen Sprechchor auf diese Berlin Demo vorm Kanzleramt.
Pupsi an.
Ja aber es gibt natürlich auch noch,
viele anderes Ungemach das droht der Bundesrat auch dass er mehr hatte ich ja hier schon so angesprochen dass sowas am Horizont droht,
der Bundesrat möchte am 15. März schon darüber diskutieren über einen Gesetzesantrag des Landes Nordrhein-Westfalen der,
ein härteres strafrechtliches Vorgehen gegen Darknet Betreiber,
vorsieht und zwar den Straftatbestand 126,
lesen uns diesen vorgeschlagenen Paragraphen mal durch verboten werden soll also das Anbieten von Leistungen zur Ermöglichung von Straftat.
Darf ich ganz kurz meine mindere Bilder zum Ausdruck bringen seit wann kann der Bundesrat Gesetzesinitiativen einbringen auf welcher Ebene dann.
Können sich Länder zusammenschließen und Gesetzesinitiativen einbringen gibt es immer wieder wurde bei dem digitalen Hausfriedensbruch und.
Aber die müssen dann doch noch vom Bundestag abgesegnet werden.
Die müssen ja die geben ihr die geben quasi ihren ihren Wunsch zu Protokoll dass das geschehen möge.
Achso okay also ja mein initiativrechte ok das war mir ehrlich gesagt noch gar nicht so klar weiter.
Also verboten werden soll nach Paragraph 126a das Anbieten von Leistungen zur Ermöglichung von Straftat,
wer eine internetbasierte Leistung anbietet deren Zugang und Erreichbarkeit durch besondere technische Vorkehrung beschränkt.
Und deren Zweck oder Tätigkeit darauf ausgerichtet ist die Begehung,
von rechtswidrigen Taten im Sinne von Satz 2 zu ermöglichen oder zu fördern wird mit Freiheitsstrafe bis zu drei Jahren oder mit Geldstrafe bestraft wenn,
die Tat nicht in anderen Vorschriften mit schwererer Strafe bedroht ist rechtswidrige Taten im Sinne des Satzes 1 sind dann kommen in wie mehrere,
fuzzy vergehen in denen das,
greifen soll also nicht jede Straftat Arzneimittelgesetz Verstöße Betäubungsmittelgesetz Verstöße grundstoffüberwachungsgesetz Verstöße Waffengesetz Verstoß Sprengstoffgesetz Verstöße,
Kriegswaffen und dann eine längere Reihe des Strafgesetzbuches wo ich nicht jeden Paragraphen kenne aber diese 202 sind mir natürlich bekannt.
Gehen wir mal davon aus auf jeden Fall eine lange,
Reihe an Gesetzen 202 sind diese ganzen Ausspähen von Daten Hacker Paragraphen und also,
denke man sieht schon Geldfälschung Geldfälschung im Darknet soll es auch verboten werden und,
woher kommt dieser ganze Kram natürlich das sind alles lehren in Anführungszeichen aus dem jedoch besonders gut gelaufenen Ermittlungsverfahren zu Deutschland in deep Web und dem Waffenhandel der dort stattgefunden hat.
War in deren Ergebnis ja ein.
Ja ausländerfeindlicher ihrer in München um sich schießen konnte und,
hier soll also jetzt der Gesetzesvorschlag eingebracht werden solche Darknet Marktplätze den Betrieb des betreiben davon unter Strafe zu setzen.
Rechtswidrige Tat.
Rechtswidrige Taten aber die sind ja die müssen ja immer benannt werden also wir haben dir Geld fälschen Kreditkartendaten fälschen und.
Ausspähen von Daten also alles was irgendwie in Richtung haking geht und dann noch den Computerbetrug also schon tatsächlich in der Form wieder jetzt formuliert ist denke ich muss man sagen sind das,
tatsächlich wahrscheinlich eine relativ spezifisch zugeschnitten.
Häufige Gesetzesverstöße die oder im Darknet Marktplätze.
Teilweise vorgefundenen Gesetzesverstöße das heißt dass ich nicht dass das so bleibt.
Wetter NRW ist auch echt ein Schmerz im Arsch in den letzten zwei Jahren oder also es ist.
Da kannst du natürlich jetzt wenn wenn man diesen Paragraphen so annimmt und dann irgendwann sagt ach mach mal noch Urheberrecht dazu ne,
dann würde natürlich diese Formulierung internetbasierte Leistung,
der Zugang und Erreichbarkeit durch besondere technisch Walking beschränkt und deren Zweck oder Tätigkeit darauf ausgerichtet ist die Begehung von rechtswidrigen Taten zu ermöglichen oder zu fördern dann wärst Du während VPN-Anbieter nach meiner Lesart des Gesetzes da mit drin.
Das ist gemein das ist ja eh die das Problem immer wenn du irgendwas ein Fürst und dann wird ausgeweitet ob das jetzt also.
Da wäre auch in meinen Augen der der Betrieb eines Tor exit.
Also die dich an Zunge und Erreichbarkeit technische Vorkehrungen beschränkt ja man muss irgendwie ne was besonderes machen da reinzukommen
weg oder Tätigkeit darauf ausgerichtet ist die Begehung von Rechts wegen Straftaten zu ermöglichen oder zu fördern ermöglichen oder fördern ist natürlich immer hartnäckig meine.
Mit nur fördern wäre wäre das was anderes wenn ich irgendwie machen mag das auf dem,
Drogen verkauft werden dann ist es das klare Förderung wenn ich jetzt irgendwie in den off in der Markplatz mache wo oder ich nehme sparbaby.de halt irgendwie was anderen VPN und dann mögliche damit das urheberrechtlich geschützte,
Daten getauscht werden wird es YouTube alles nach abgewandert ist ins dark web.
Gleich im Knast mit dir.
Also das ist ich glaube auch ein ein Spiel mit dem Feuer vor allem weil ich.
Denke das.
Mir nicht bekannt ist das Betreiberin einer mein relativ einer Nr für diesen Zweck,
wirklich bereitgestellten Plattform arzneimittelhandel Betäubungsmittel Waffengesetz oder sowas ne die werden ja sowieso alle des Tatbestands der Beihilfe schuldig,
und das finde ich glaube ich sehr viel sinnvoller als hier noch mal spezifisch Zusagen internetbasierte Leistung die das ermöglicht das geht glaube ich,
gerne mal schief da selbst wenn der Paragraph so durchgehen würde,
wenn innerhalb der nächsten zwei Jahre noch ein paar Schutzlücken identifiziert werden die am Ende dazu führen dass das.
Das keine Ahnung ne posteo Ärger kriegt weil sie keine Logs haben weil das Straftaten ermöglicht.
Genau das ist ja die Fortsetzung davon könnte sein bei
almanda juristischen Unkenntnis bringt Essenskarte man das sehr schnell hat eben ausweiten und daneben auch Dienste de
irgendwann hast noch mal und legal nutzen wenn man mit ein bisschen Privatsphäre unterwegs sein will irgendwie dann in den Fokus geraten können.
In der Kurzmeldung die auf bundesrat.de veröffentlicht wird gesagt wenn diese Straftaten wie das Verbreiten von Rauschgift Sprengstoff oder Kinderpornografie ermöglichen ja da ist es auch noch mal ganz klar gesagt damit,
ermöglichen der Zweck wird ja gar nicht mehr so so groß geschrieben gleichzeitig
ist das Verbreiten von Rauschgift Sprengstoff und Kinderpornographie nach meiner Kenntnis als ich das letzte mal geprüft habe ohnehin verboten insofern,
erkenne ich nicht so ganz.
Das ist hier eine Schutzlücke gebe die eines spezifischen Gesetz ist bedürfen würde.
Das hier potentiell noch mal Flurschaden anrichtet gleichzeitig so wie es im Moment formuliert ist sie also in dieser Formulierung sehe ich gerade noch noch nicht eine direkte,
einen direkten Flurschaden ich sehe aber dass der im Prinzip mit mit einem, oder einen der in dem Ändern eines Verbs da sofort.
Schnell entstehen kann.
Gute muss man sagen dass ein Vorschlag des oder Initiative des Bundesrats frag mich wie das in der Koalition ankommt weil das Thema dürfte wahrscheinlich.
Verbieten kommt glaube ich gut an.
Ja stehe aber jetzt so nicht im Koalitionsvertrag ne.
Uploadfilter standen sogar spezifisch nicht im Quali.
Ja ich weiß ich weiß.
Also ich habe das kommt gut an weil der BMI hatte auf dem europäischen Polizeikongress der letztens hier in Berlin stattfand wo exportiert mal wieder keine Akkreditierung bekommen hatte hatte der Vertreter des BMI der Staatssekretär Krings auch gesagt,
in die ähnliche Kerbe gehauen und das ist sicher so dass das sieht so aus als würde die Bundesregierung da sagen guter Vorschlag hat das Nebenwirkungen auf.
Auf jeden Fall und das hat die hat das ist eben auch Teil des Eckpunktepapier ist für das AT Sicherheits gesetzt über das war ja auch schon gesprochen haben das wird kommen.
Was haben wir in der Zeit eigentlich für Mehrheitsverhältnisse im Bundesrat das ist ja recht bunt,
na ja der ist wirklich mega bunt also es ist gucke gerade mal hier drauf wir haben fast kein nee es gibt ja krass gibt kein einziges Land mehr was nicht von einer Koalition regiert wird,
buntes alles vertreten es fällt mir gerade schwer hier die märzfeld ist heraus zu lesen.
Der da unten Einblick wie es da gerade aussieht aber zwei Pfeil drauf hauen können sie ja alle.
Spontane kenne ich die Mehrzeit nisse nicht in der.
Bist also wenn man sich das Bild hier anschaut ist für dich vorkommen verwirren.
Alexianer auch immer so Vereinbarung das ist quasi wenn das jetzt irgendwie meinem kollektions Partner widerspricht dass man sich das hier sehen würde enthalten oder dann dafür also es wird ja dann quasi rückfahr handelt in die in die eigene Koalition.
Also hast du Beispiel neun Länder neun Länder wo nicht drüber die Grünen in der Koalition.
So von 16 man ja meinen mit meiner Meinung dass wenn die Grünen dagegen werden dass sich keiner da wirklich für aussprechen kann wenn dem so ist.
Das gleiche gilt natürlich dann auch für die Linken das wäre das noch mal ein Land mehr.
Richtig ich halte das tatsächlich für,
unerheblich was der Bundesrat da entscheidet oder nicht weil kriminelle Infrastrukturen im Internet effektiv bekämpfen Einführen einer Strafbarkeit des Betreibens krimineller Infrastrukturen im Internet insbesondere Darknet ist Teil des
Eckpunktepapier für das AT sicher.
So das hat und dieses Eckpunktepapier kommt natürlich aus dem Innenministerium der kann der Bundesrat jetzt sagen was er will das wird eh
komm das könnte sogar sein dass einfach nur mal aus dem Bundesrat kommt damit die nachher so tun können als hätten sie auch auf dem Bundesrat ein bisschen gehört.
Also das wird.
Ruft sie an.
See an ride Europa.
Die hatten schon berichtet über Fingerabdrücke im Personalausweis oder in den EU identitätsdokumente
hier geht das gerade durchs europäisch Parlament konkret durch die Liebe Ausschuss also der der für bürgerliche Freiheiten Justiz und Inneres zuständig ist.
Und der soll diesen Entwurf bestätigen danach müssen noch Parlament und Mitgliedstaaten zustimmen Deutschland,
wird das wohl tun und Seehofer nicht das Gesetz zwingend erforderlich.
Ich merke aber ich kann gar nicht abwarten dass ich endlich meine Fingerabdrücke in den in den Personalausweis speichern kann.
Genau dient meiner eigenen Sicherheit wir haben glaube ich über Biometrie hier schon sehr oft gesprochen als Sicherungs Merkmal für mich wenn ich das benutzen möchtest Biometrie sehr.
Sehr wenig geeignet,
weil ich dieses dieses biometrische Passwort ja nicht mehr ändern kann außer durch schwerere Operationen kann ich mich von diesem Passwort noch einmal trennen als,
identifikations Maßnahme gegen mich sind natürlich solche biometrischen Merkmale sehr gut geeignet das Problem ist aber weniger ob jetzt der Fingerabdruck eben.
Personalausweis auf der Smartcard gespeichert wird und von geeigneten Lesegeräten und berechtigten Lesern ausgelesen werden kann das Problem ist,
das seit dem Gesetz zur Förderung des elektronischen Personalausweises welches 2017 erlassen wurde wo wir als Chaos Computer Club auch eine Stellungnahme zugeschrieben hatten wenn ich mich nicht täusche wann das Constanze,
Starbuck und ich kann sein dass ich bin gleich sicher ob ich da mit drauf stehe da geht es jetzt darum dass viele Meldebehörden,
das dass Didi Polizist Polizeibehörde Ermittlungsbehörden bei den Meldebehörden automatisch die Daten abfragen dürfen darunter auch eben die biometrischen Daten,
und nach dieser Lesart Vallendar,
gilt wenn ich das recht erinnere haben wir da nur hauptsächlich über das biometrische Passbild gesprochen weil kaum jemand seine Fingerabdrücke in den Personalausweis,
einfügt aber das würde natürlich rucki zucki auch dazu führen dass du dann eine bundesweite Fingerabdruck Datenbank.
Das ist der nächste Schritt in meines vadis diese Abfrage mit dem automatisch Papas Bild war ja früher so oder muss ich in Kleinkleckersdorf beim Amt und dann können Sie uns bitte das Bild schicken und dann habe ich es Bild irgendwie jetzt bin ich automatisch abfragen kann kann ich mit heutige Gesicht Biometrie Ding machen Bild von einer Demonstration
und dann brauche ich die automatische Abfrage und dann habe ich die Teilnehmerliste ist sehr gut fürs Demonstration zum Versammlungsrecht natürlich wenn die Leute immer komplett beobachtet da ist ein riesen Gefahren ich halt das für eines der gefährlichsten Gesetze der letzten Jahre diese automatisierte Abfrage,
kommen noch Fingerabdrücke dazu dann.
Fingerabdrücke dazu und also es geht hier nicht darum,
den Personalausweis zu sichern es geht darum diese Fingerabdruck Datenbank in großer in großer Menge am Ende zu.
Das ist.
Single.
Na ja was habt ihr denn jetzt für doch alles gut Facebook,
macht jetzt voll auf Datenschutz und die Welt ist gerettet.
Alles ende-zu-ende das wird richtig gute Fette zum Datenschutz Konzern hat immer gesagt.
Hihihihihi aber er hat auch zugegeben dass er sich vorstellen kann dass einige Leute dafür nicht glaubwürdig halten wenn er das sagt hat er es auch zu politischen Aschermittwoch gesagt eigentlich Anne.
Gebildet möchte dass wir ihm die seine ganzen ganzen Daten geben damit du sie beschützt.
Naja also ich glaube Weltkonzern Ankündigungen ist die große regelein ich immer das erstmal nicht zu kommunizieren und zu gucken was dann am Ende rauskommt weil man gucken wir mal sehen wie weit das da also,
wenn es wirklich passiert ist war schön.
Ja aber weißt du die die einzige wirkliche Ankündigung ist ja die ja auch schon vor einiger Zeit gemacht hat dass er sagt okay
wir werden jetzt immer mehr Angebote eine Ende-zu-Ende-Verschlüsselung nach dem Vorbild von Whatsapp angedeihen lassen und das erste was er daraus gemacht hat war ja wir Merchant die Daten von Whatsapp Facebook und insta.
Sniper Force Kartellamt irgendwie reagieren kann.
Und jetzt sagt er als nächstes macht er das dann würde er Plan das mit Videochat E-Commerce und Bezahlservice ist irgendwie zu machen,
ich bin aber sehr gespannt aber es ist natürlich klar dass bisher noch kein Unternehmen gekommen ist und gesagt hat wir schaffen unser Geschäftsmodell ab und insbesondere Facebook.
Das nicht getan insofern.
Wie hoch ist der Glaubwürdigkeit Skala von 1 bis Datenschutz Glaubwürdigkeit.
Letztens dass es da ist er glaube ich da hat er zu spät gecheckt ne das hat er der Tim Pritlove fertig jetzt schon fast gesagt.
Zimmerbörse.
Der Apple Tim der Datingseite Tim Apple.
Wird schon bin jetzt so genannt hat.
Wäre der neben ihm saß.
Nach soweit Franzi nicht vorstellen kann dass meine Firma nach irgendwas anderem benennt als ich selbst.
Und offensichtlich hat der ja den Laden gegründet also was gibt Jobcenter bei Scheidung.
Gewerbe.
Geil dr michael Geld im Apple.
Und Chef Amazon und Larry Google.
Genau genau und Mark face.
Bomann.
Wo ist das naja es ist hast du ja auch Linus Neumann Podcast.
Jetzt verstehe ich endlich diese Abkürzung.
Was ist das eine reine eine personelle die Scharia.
Tim Apple hat das hingekriegt mit dem Datenschutz als Markenkern bin ich mal gespannt,
ja wieder ein auch auch lustig wir war ja immer eine lustige Meldungen haben,
hör mir doch mal zu einer weniger lustigen Meldung Philipp Ruch.
Was ist was ist Philippos aktuelle Bezeichnung beim Zentrum für politische Schönheit.
Ich vermute künstlerischer Leiter weil ich weiß es nicht genau.
Heißt der wirklich Philipp Zentrum für politische.
Dachte er ist erst Eskalation Sport.
Nein das ist Stefan Pet.
Ach so anschreien.
Genau und ist das Innenministerium hat ein Auftrittsverbot für gegen Philipp Ruch erlassen,
höchster Ebene und zwar sollte der beim Kongress der Bundeszentrale für politische Bildung in Leipzig zu dem Motto was uns bewegt Emotionen in Politik und Gesellschaft boah ich ganz gut hin passt die Aktion,
bitte Zentrum für politische Schönheit Antwort von höchster Ebene ausgeladen,
und raucht mit der Begründung SMS dass das
sie zur Spaltung der Gesellschaft war sie Beitrag also nicht die mit dem mit der Aktion soko-chemnitz also nicht die Nazis dort die hat der Straße irgendwie Leute jagen diesen die Spaltung Gesellschaft dandidis anprangern es ist schon mal eine interessante sich darauf und das wurde dann,
auch gesagt es ist lieb ein laufendes Verfahren davon wusste Philipp auch nach eigener Aussage nicht dass da ein Verfahren läuft was ich daran
kritisch finde ist das hier das jetzt also schon Künstler durch Erlass des Innenministers bei Konferenzen nicht mehr reden dürfen okay das ist
Konferenz des Innenministeriums zentral Verbindung ist im Innenministerium untergeordnet hat das auch die Kohle vom Innenministerium natürlich aber das ist schon ein starkes Stück irgendwie gegen Kunst so vorzugehen.
Vor allem wenn man also jetzt wo die Aktion soko-chemnitz einige Zeit her ist ne habe ja auch mal,
durchaus darüber sprechen dass sie halt sehr elegant war weil dann nämlich genau nicht ein
tatsächlicher Pranger so gestaltet wurde sondern sie ja nachher gesagt haben das war ein Honeypot damit ihr hier möglichst viele Namen eingibt
ja und das fand ich ja zumindest kann man nicht sagen dass das eine,
eine rechtswidrige Aktion entsprechend gibt's ja auch keine rechtlichen handhaben.
Na das ist Mysterium sagt er was von Verfahren also.
Ignite bin ich mal gespannt in Mission sagt sagt wörtlich,
wir können uns nicht leisten staatliche Behörde gilt es für uns zu vermeiden unmittelbar oder auch möglicherweise mittelbar auf ein laufendes Verfahren einzuwirken was kann das denn für ein Verfahren sein.
Keine Ahnung was das strafrechtlich.
Also es könnte natürlich immer noch ein polizeiliches Ermittlungsverfahren geben.
Und er dann nie die Person nichts weiß aber ja.
Das ist schon stark also das ist schon echt stark dass die sich die Blöße geben mehr und ihm diese diese hohe Auszeichnung man wäre ich stolz ey.
Ich habe das ganz sicher wahrscheinlich als Spenden Grund auch die Webseiten,
na ja aber ich werde von Fotohintergrund natürlich wie der Aberkennung von Gemeinnützigkeit bei Atak und so
ist das hatte ich schon auch gefährlich für eine für Künstler dienen mit einem gemeinnützigen Verein das machen also da ist dann so ein Drohpotential drin was man eigentlich Demokratie nicht sehen will.
Tanzverein mach eine extreme Schädigung der Bundeszentrale für politische Bildung.
Die Unabhängigkeit von der ja.
Also das Mega das da rein weil ich meine bpb mag Mixpack sein aber,
sehr viele sehr interessante Initiativen Projekte Konferenzen etc
sind von der bpb in den letzten Jahren immer wieder finanziert worden und durchgeführt worden und das ist natürlich jetzt für dich ein Schlag ins Gesicht auch für dienen also,
den würde ich aber.
Und die hat so hat der tatsächlichen ziemlich guten Ruf die bpb ne das muss man echt mal sagen so den hatte bisher noch wenige hat es bisher geschafft den zu ruinieren,
oder den überhaupt auch nur an ankratzen zulassen ne und jetzt nagut unter Seehofer ist das natürlich,
eine Frage von 2-3 Weizen das Ding EW kurz da in die Tonne zu reißen aber das ist schon.
Das crass also,
übliche Erlass also ich meine damit regiert ja quasi das Innenministerium direkt in etwas hinein was zumindest den Nimbus einer Unabhängigkeit hat meine dass der faktische jetzt nicht vorliegt gutes das merkt man jetzt aber trotz alledem ist das
keine gute Aktion könnte mir durchaus vorstellen dass ich jetzt auch weitere Künstler zittere aus entsprechenden
Projekten zurückziehen wird man sehen aber kann ich mir auf jeden Fall vorstellen und ob das jetzt so zielführend ist was.
Also etwas einfach nicht habe dann gestern nachgeschaut irgendwie oder kann man das schöne IFG Anfrage machen wollte das machen ohne hat das Arne semsrott.
Alle Kommunikation der Bundeszentrale für diesen Fall das wird sicher spannend was da rauskommt.
Oh ja = deshalb hat das finden wir schon auf frag den Staat okay.
Bitte spiele manchmal frag den Staat also der ist schneller als Seehofer Verbot aussprechen kann.
Nicht schlecht nicht schlecht.
So wunderbar.
Das heißt für uns wir kommen zu den Termin sehe ich das richtig.
Ich denke schon.
Naja dann mach mal das doch mal.
So viel gibt's da auch gar nicht heute in unserem Beutelchen aber ich möchte mal auf eine Infoveranstaltung,
meine lieblings Fußballverein hinweisen und zwar,
beim ersten fC Union Berlin gibt's mir an Infoveranstaltung zum Polizeigesetz zum geplanten,
in Berlin sich schreiben Handgranaten und Maschinengewehre für die Polizei Staatstrojaner zum Auslesen von laufender Kommunikation Fußfesseln und aufteilt Anordnung für sogenannte Gefährder Sprengstoff Kontrollen aller Fahrzeuginsassen bei Verkehrskontrollen,
das ist nur eine Auswahl der neuen gesetzlichen Bestimmungen die zuletzt in mehreren Bundesländern eingeführt worden Kern der neuen Polizeigesetze ist die Einführung des Rechts Begriff der drohenden Gefahr,
wird diese vermutet kann die Polizei entspricht aktiv werden,
einen konkreten Vorwurf oder gar einen Beweis braucht die Polizei nicht mehr die Unschuldsvermutung gilt entsprechend nicht mehr Polizei Tätigkeit beginnt dann schon wenn noch gar keine konkrete straft hat abzusehen ist.
Polizei wird weiter mit arisiert und geheimdienstliche Methoden für die Polizei werden legalisiert die Methoden des sogenannten Anti-Terror-Kampf treffen dann alle vermeintlichen Gefährder unter Umständen auch Fußballfan,
in Berlin gibt es ein solches Gesetz noch nicht seit Januar 2019 wird aber darüber diskutiert ein solches zu erlassen,
warum ein solches solches Gesetz nicht benötigt und welche Konsequenzen dies konkret auch für Fußballfans haben könnte wollen wir gemeinsam mit euch diskutieren,
das Bier ist in dem Fall die eiserne Hilfe das ist halt eine Gruppe die sich quasi als Rechtsberatung für Fußballfans war sowas gibt's ja in vielen Vereinen mittlerweile,
sind auch relativ aktiv und muss auch sagen gerade Fußball sehen ist enorm davon betroffen also da gibt's viele Fälle und es werden auch immer mehr,
wo halt hier diese Polizeigesetz oder generell auch ohne Gesetze Leute einfach mal Kollektiv eingesammelt werden das ganze findet statt am 12,
März in den Räumen im Stadion an der Alten Försterei in Berlin-Köpenick.
Die ganzen Demos natürlich die jetzt stattfinden in Deutschland am 9.03 am 17.03 und vor allem am 23 März dann genau dazu gibt's Übersicht auf Netzpolitik.
Am 04.05 haben wir ja schon angekündigt gibt's dann noch einen logbuch-netzpolitik 300 in Berlin,
und am 26.05 gibt's Europawahl Europawahl um ihren bisschen beim Fußball zu bleiben können.
Europawahl Dammer.
Das hat mir direkt gemerkt dass der Termin nicht besonders interessiert glaube das die längste Terminankündigung die wir je hatten.
Na und wenn schon.
Auf jeden Fall bis gespannt wer eine Europawahl alles total neben wird welche Mannschaften aufgestellt wer.
Welche.
Genau ich hab.
Hintergründe.
Ich hoffe und denke auch immer noch die Briten werden irgendwie dabei sein muss.
In der Nachspielzeit oder.
Ja die beantrage gerade Nachspielzeit und ja ja naja also sind auf jeden Fall bald.
Bald fällig also das eskaliert,
gerade total ich weiß keine hatte ich darauf hingewiesen habe ich glaube ich drauf hingewiesen dass ich zum brexit eine etwas ausführlichere Sendung immer habe ich schon drauf hingewiesen habe ich jetzt noch mal gemacht ich Alter ab Lager,
wird spannend also auf jeden Fall das,
eskaliert ja mega da gerade in Britannien also die die Dummheit ist wirklich enorm und das wird ein Shootout.
Ja und ihr vermissen auch noch 5 € in der Kiste ne.
Muss ja wieder zurückgewinnen gut.
Anschließend gibt's da noch einen kleinen Jingle zuhören und der uns aus Salzburg zugespielt wurde.
Unicom natürlich auch einfach ummodeln auf andere Städte damit sind wir glaube ich aber Ende der Sendung.
So sind wir genau Markus vielen Dank fürs Kommen.
Bitte bitte gerne.
Danke auch noch mal an martin für seinen generellen Beitrag und für das Auftauchen in dieser Sendung und vielen Dank an euch fürs zuhören und einschalten und weiterempfehlen und all das wie immer zusammen geschissen bis bald.
Silvia Internet europaweit Aktionstag gegen uploadfilter und Leistungsschutzrecht für einen Preis Internet
Sortimo am 23 März um 14 Uhr am Hauptbahnhof Salzburg
mehr auf city-internet. Info lasst unser Internet in Ruhe oder wir nehmen eure Faxgerät.